.
IN
In the last video I said the result we got for the person
of a triangle having sides of a, b, and c lengths
is equivalent to the Heron formula.
And what I want to do in this video is to show you that it is
equivalent to Heron's formula, essentially simply using the
multiple algebraic manipulations.
The first thing we want to do - let's just put that
1 / 2c below the root sign.
1 / 2c, this is the same thing as a square root
from c square to 4.
Take a square root of this and get 1 / 2c.
This whole expression is equal to - instead of drawing
roots, I will just write the square root of this,
the c square on 4, multiplied by all.
I'll just copy it.
All this.
Copy and set.
So multiplied by all this.
And of course, they must be separated.
with a square on 4 multiplied by that.
And then we have to close the square root.
And then, this thing ...
Let's just divide c square on 4.
This will be equal to the square root.
This will be complicated, but I think you will find it
to be satisfactory to see how this can turn into something so
just like the Heron formula.
Square root of c square on 4, multiplied by a square is c
square, and square to 4, minus square to 4.
I just distribute this.
I will write it as the numerator of a square on
denominator of a square.
Multiplied by a square plus a square, minus b
a square, the whole square.
On - if you pick up the square the denominator - it's 4c per square.
4c per square.
And we immediately see that with a square and a square
will be canceled.
Let me close all the brackets like this.
And, of course, this 4 on this 4, this will be
reflect in - let me write it this way.
It's the same thing as 4 on a square.
And instead of writing 16, you will see why
I write this.
Now I can write this again,
as ...
This will be equal to the square root -
I randomly change the colors - from ca to 2 per square.
as on 2 per square
This is the same thing as this.
No?
I just write it like the whole thing in a square.
If you pick up this square, it's c in a square and square in 2
square on 4, minus - I will write this whole thing
as a square expression.
This is c on a square plus a square, minus
b per square, on 4.
And we lift the square and the numerator, and the denominator.
We pick up the square and the numerator, and the denominator.
Now, this may seem a little interesting to you.
Let's make the brackets in a slightly different color.
Maybe you remember the decomposition of polynomials that if
i have something of the kind of x of a square minus y of a square, that
decomposes to x plus y, x minus y.
And we will use it again and again.
Now if we call ca on 2 - x and we call this big thing
y, then we have x per square y y per square.
So, we can break it down.
This whole thing will be equal to the square root of
x plus y, or in this case is ca on 2 plus y, which is
c on a square plus a square, minus b per square on 4.
Multiplied by x minus y.
So, this is our x.
are on 2, minus all of these things here.
Or even better, let's just say plus then
just write the negative ones.
So, plus c minus a square, minus a square, plus b per square.
All this on 4.
All I did here is that I said it was the same thing as that
plus this, plus this, multiplied by this minus that, that
minus - I just said the negative one.
The c minus square, minus a square, plus b per square.
All I did was there.
Now let's see if we can simplify this, or if
we can add these fractions.
We can get a common denominator.
are on 2, it's the same as 2ca on 4.
are on 2, it's the same as 2ca on 4, just
we multiply the numerator and the denominator by 2.
And now we can add numerators.
So, our entire expression now will be equal to the square
root of this first expression will become - and I will
I write it this way.
I will write c on a square plus 2ca, plus a square, minus b
a square, all this on 4.
This is our first expression.
And then our second expression will be - well,
everything will be on 4, I will just write
this now.
Everything on 4.
We can write this by taking a square.
And then we can write this as b for a square, minus square,
minus 2ca, plus a square.
Just to make sure I have a minus a square here.
Plus, multiplied by minus, is still minus a square.
I have plus 2ca here.
Minus multiplied by minus, this is plus 2ca.
I have a minus c per square here.
So, these two things are equivalent.
The next thing we need to distinguish, or I hope we can
we can see that this here - can get a little
scattered - it's the same thing as c plus a square.
Let me write this.
This is equal to the square root of, I open the brackets, this
here is c plus a square, minus b square, on 4.
This is this first article.
And then the second member.
This is the same as c minus a square.
So, this whole thing will be simplified to b per square
minus with, minus a square, all this on 4.
We have made some progress.
As I said, this is a complex task.
But we see some clean applications of decomposition on
polynomials and see how strange it looks
equation can be turned into simple.
Now we can use the same way - we have this one
pattern - something of a square minus something else in a square.
Something about a square minus something else in a square.
So, we can break it down.
I will do it in the same order.
This will be equal to - I will write it
a little less so as not to be out of place -
square root.
This will be decomposed into this plus this.
So, plus a, plus b, multiplied by c, plus a, minus b.
No?
That's exactly the same pattern I've done here.
This is x of a square, y is a square.
Multiplied by c plus a, minus b, all this on 4.
And then we get this.
This will be b plus with, minus a.
We will have b plus with, minus a.
Let me turn a little to the right.
B plus c minus a - it is x plus y - multiplied by
b minus c, min a.
Or this is the same thing as b minus with, plus a.
This is the same thing as b minus with, minus a.
No?
All right.
And all this on 4.
Now I can rewrite this whole expression.
I do not want to be out of place.
I can rewrite the whole expression as - 4e
the work of 2 in 2.
4 is the work of 2 by 2.
The whole of our expression is undoubtedly simplified
to the fact that it is equal to a square root - and this is really the last one
stage - to this one, which I can just write like
a plus b, plus c on 2.
This is the member there.
Multiplied by this article.
Let me write the simplification here. c plus a,
minus b, this is the same thing as a plus b, plus c, minus 2b.
These two things are equivalent.
No?
You have a, you have c, and then b, minus 2b, will be
equal to minus b.
No? b minus 2b, this is minus b.
So, this next member will be plus plus b plus
c minus 2b, on 2.
Or instead of writing it this way, let me write this
on 2, minus 2.
And then our next article here.
Exactly the same logic.
This is the same thing as a plus b, plus c, minus 2a,
all this on 2.
No?
If we add minus 2a to a, we get a minus a.
So, we get b plus with, minus a.
These are the same things.
All this on 2 or we can divide the denominators,
just like that on 2.
And then one last member.
You may already have recognized the
The heroonic formula that is displayed.
I did not mean Heron's rule - the Heron formula.
This article is exactly the same thing as
plus plus b, plus c, minus 2c.
No?
You subtract 2c from c, you get minus c and then
you still have a and b.
And then all this on 2.
You can type this on 2, minus 2.
And of course we take the square root
of all these things.
If we determine that S equals a plus b, plus c with
2, then, this equation is greatly simplified.
This is S.
That's where S.
And that's where S.
And this is also being simplified a lot.
Minus 2b on 2, this is exactly the same thing as minus b.
Minus 2a on 2, it's the same thing as minus.
Minus 2c on 2, this is the same thing as minus c.
So, this whole equation for our face now is equal to - will
rewrite the square root.
The square, square root of S - that's exactly there.
From S on
I will do it in the same colors.
Multiplied by S minus b, this is S minus a, and we are
of the last one - S minus c.
S minus c.
We have proved that the Heron formula is exactly the same thing
like what turned out at the end of the last video.
That was quite clear.
And we just had to use some complicated algebra,
to prove it in reality.